the night king is coming
the dead are already here
hi everyone it's charlie this is going
to be my game of thrones season 8
episode 3 battle we have
so much stuff to talk about what do we
say to the god of death
not today so if you're new to the
channel we're doing game of thrones
videos all season
be sure to subscribe to get everything
it's only getting crazier we're doing
the hbo now giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video
there's so many epic things to talk
about in this episode but obviously
careful for spoilers if you have not
seen the episode yet because they pulled
some
really big left turns we'll do top 15
wtf
and easter eggs from the books just like
normal so starting with number 15
the new opening credits so if you notice
they've been changing the opening
credits based on what's been happening
in each episode the big changes this
week were mostly around winterfell just
to highlight the big battle so you see
the blue tiles
flipping down all the way down to
winterfell and you see all the trenches
open up with their troops in formation
so presumably as we move down to king's
landing in the next couple of episodes
we'll slowly see the tiles flipping over
reflecting that and we'll spend more
time on the map down there
but because there was so much battle
damage to winterfell don't be surprised
if in next week's opening credits they
also do the same thing
just like they did it when theon sacked
winterfell during season two and you saw
the black smoke pluming out
but number fourteen they opened the
episode from sam's perspective it's
actually a brilliant way to do it it's
like r2d2 and c3po opening star wars you
open with like the lesser characters and
you get their perspective because he's
freaking out his hands are shaking and
all the troops are marching by
everyone is in battle mode you get the
big wide shots that we saw in all the
trailers you see the unsullied legions
you see their ballistas in front of them
you see the dothraki blood writers in
front of them and you get a couple
different groups so they would jump
around to the different groups during
the episode and that's how they sort of
broke the battle up because they were
referring to this episode like their
version of the battle of helm's deep
from lord of the rings the two towers
but in that battle you actually have the
battle of eisenguard happening so you
would bounce back and forth
between the two battles and in this case
we were just at winterfell so miguel
sapochnick when he was doing interviews
about how he filmed the episode
he said that he used these different
groups of people particularly the people
down in the crypts to sort of bounce
back and forth so that it wasn't just
wall-to-wall action like all the arya
stuff
when she was inside winterfell in the
middle of the episode was just pure
suspense it was something right out of a
hitchcock movie
so i thought they did a good job with
the structure of the episode just to
keep you from getting too fatigued with
all the dog piles
almost every single main character got
dog piled at some point particularly
brienne
and jamie they had a couple really great
moments fighting together even though
the episode didn't feature them
quite as much as it did the starks
primarily the stark characters
because we're at winterfell it's their
home so even though daenerys is
obviously a really really big character
you don't spend quite as much time with
her as you do with jon
snow it's just that you see her a lot
because she's fighting with jon snow and
drogon and regal
but basically the different groups you
have are you have cerdavo sort of off by
himself but he's kind of briefly with
arya for a little while you have sansa
and arya but then sansa goes to the
crypts and she's with tyrion
and varys gilly and little sam for the
rest of the episode
like i said jon snow and daenerys flying
around overhead with drogon and regal
throughout the episode
thankfully they both survived none the
worst for wear even though they both go
down at various points
they really wanted you to wonder if they
were going to kill another one of the
dragons
brienne is with pod jaime in the knights
of the vale or at least they start off
together but for the most part
pod stays with jamie bryant and then by
the time they were treated tormund
wasn't too far away from them but you
have to imagine that
by the time they've retreated to the
courtyard everyone is in that really
tight enclosed space
surprise appearance from a very good boy
on the battlefield very prominently
featured at the line of dothraki
bloodriders with sergiora wielding
heartsbane
you have barrick fighting with the hound
tormund gendry ed
and samwell all with the rest of the
wildlings and the remaining night's
watch brothers
i love everything about the first 15
minutes of the episode just the silence
before they actually write out for the
first time before that happens though
number 13 welcome back melisandre i was
a little surprised she didn't bring any
of the other red priestesses back with
her or any of the fiery hand
but i think they did a good job using
her during the episode as much as they
needed to
like the episode went down i think a
little bit differently than everyone
expected we all knew that there would be
some twists but they mainly used her for
the fire twist and to remind you about
that season three scene that she had
with arya
prophesying all the eyes that she would
shut turns out those blue eyes pretty
important so for all the disgraceful
shireen burnings you can't say that she
didn't at least get a couple of her
prophecies right on the money
she lights all the dothraki torches up
it's this really good rally cry moment
they all get really hyped up before they
write out for the first time
and practically it's a really good
visual tool to help us the audience
see what's going on on screen because
they're lighting the battlefield up but
number 12 that very first assault with
the dothraki and sergiora so they write
out their super charge because of what
melisandre has done
but i love the way you see them right
off into the blackness of night in the
really clever way that they let you know
how
terrible and insurmountable the odds are
is is that you slowly hear the dothraki
cries
getting quieter and quieter and you
slowly see their lit
weapons go out one by one until
it's dead quiet in black again and you
start to see them straggling back you
see sir jorah shake his head at tormund
as he rise by nope not happening
daenerys is the first one to remount
drogon and take him into battle so
obviously that's when they start the
first wave number 11 of whites just
washing over all their forces starting
with the unsullied like this sea
of undead you can literally see some of
the whites crawling on top of the
unsullied because their formations are
so
tight they have that really funny
callback with sansa and arya where she's
like you go to the crips now
hands are a dragonglass dagger i don't
know how to use it stick them with the
pointy end just like jon snow told her
during season one episode two so number
10 sons of tyrion and everything that
happened in the crypts so they actually
have some really great moments between
sons and tyrion they're mostly using
them for the perspective down there you
kind of enter through sansa's
perspective
just as we predicted the whites were
able to tunnel in through the side they
didn't come through the front door
just like they did when they were
entering the three-eyed ravens tree
during season six when they were coming
for him tyrion is actually really upset
kind of getting a little bit drunk even
though it might not seem that important
that he's upset
like i could offer something i could
help them do something that they might
not otherwise think of
if i were up there sansa tries to tell
him no you would just die i would
die there's nothing we can do we need to
face the truth that's the bravest thing
we can do now
even though that seems like a bit of a
throwaway line in the moment i think
it's actually really important for
tyrion's character this season
for those of you that are wondering
whether or not there's going to be some
big betrayal this season
i think they're sort of laying the seeds
in tyrion here so just think about how
upset he is about how he's being pushed
to the side people aren't listening to
him i won the battle of blackwater he
tells them all he started to remind them
about all the good decisions he made in
the first couple of seasons
even though he's been making terrible
decisions the last couple of seasons
we're up against his sister in the last
half of the season
jaime's there as well so just think
about what's going to happen with tyrion
in the next couple of episodes keep your
eyes peeled on the way that he reacts to
all the battle planning that happens
during episode four
but i do love the way that sansa treats
him when they're down there joking about
being married you were the best of them
the good the bad and the ugly husbands
that she was forced to marry at various
points like she almost got married to
joffrey so i consider him in that group
but then you have ramsay and tyrion who
she actually did get married to
so number 10 though as predicted the
night king did not enter until way later
in the episode
but you do see his magic early on with
that giant winter storm that he creates
to create some cloud cover and make it
harder for jon snow and daenerys to use
the dragons
it's actually a pretty ingenious use of
his magic it makes it harder for all the
troops to see and later when they're
trying to light the torches
the wind keeps blowing everything out
while the whites are also taking down
the torchbearers
the storm is so thick that it also
causes drogon and rhaegal to collide
midair john and daenerys almost fall off
the dragons they recover pretty quickly
thankfully the way they lit the episode
it was actually pretty easy to follow
the action even when there were three
dragons on screen
going at each other but a little bit of
that is because of viserion's blue flame
in the regular dragon's red flame
they had a really great moment later in
the episode too when bran wargs the
ravens to get a really up close look and
see
exactly what he's doing and you get a
really cool perspective shot of him
reaching out almost as if towards you
reaching out towards
camera but really he's reaching out to
command the whites we didn't quite get
the wizard battle between the night king
and brand that i was expecting this
episode but they did share
a really interesting moment right before
he was killed by arya that i'll talk
about when we get later on my list
obviously that much bigger stuff is much
lower on my list but number eight
15 minutes in we finally get our first
big character death
r.i.p ed he goes down saving samwell at
least helps him get back to the castle
get up
charlie samwell got dogpiled in this
episode almost as many times as brienne
and jaime got dogpiled
grey worm helps them protect their
retreat as they get ready to light the
trenches
because he destroys the barrier for the
trench while the unsullied legions are
on the other side
protecting their retreats so i was like
wait a minute is he leaving his men
behind to die
even though they probably had no qualms
about that they're not like regular
soldiers they have no problem taking
orders like that
but number seven melisandre has to light
the trenches because of that winter
storm and there's even a brief moment
where her faith seems like it wavers and
she's getting kind of worried
but it's all just to build suspense as
she lights them the same way she lit the
dothraki weapons so the fire sort of
trails around
lighting up winterfell everything about
the way they lit the episode
with fire with the dragon fire when
daenerys would ride into battle
it was all beautiful almost every big
frame like that in the episode was a
painting
particularly when they had the three-way
dragon battle in the air
number six theon tries to have that
final moment with bran apologizing for
what he did
bran gives him the speech everything you
did brought you to where you are here it
brought you back home
so this is actually important for the
arya stuff at the end of the episode too
when she kills the night king
because think about it this way he's
basically telling theon that if you had
done things differently you would not be
here now
protecting me and theon is actually
pretty badass during the episode
just look at all the white bodies around
him even though it seems like he did
that by himself there are other ironborn
around the godswood it's just this late
in the battle they've all gone down so
it's just
theon and bran by the end but before
that happens there's a lot of stuff
happening with all the other characters
that i don't want to skip over like
brienne saves
jamie from a dog pile just like jamie
saved her earlier in the episode from a
separate dog pile
they fight back to back for a little
while the hound completely lost his [ __ ]
when they lit the trenches with all the
dead writhing
in and around the flames just giving you
big flashbacks to blackwater
the only thing that really shook him
back to consciousness that actually
brought him back into the battle was the
threat of arya dying merrick points her
out and that drives them into arya's
storyline during the episode but before
we talk about that
number five the little bear versus the
giant white so if you weren't sure which
giant this was
it wasn't one one because john burned
his body so it was one of the other
giants and i felt like they gave her a
pretty good way to go out and
really cool brought her back when the
night king raised all the dead
four was daenerys and jon snow's
three-way dragon battle with the night
king mid-air
so they try to take him on he actually
gets him pretty good almost gets
daenerys but john and rhaegal managed to
claw like
half of viserion's face away which
apparently didn't slow him down at all
because at the end of the episode when
viserion was just
laying blue flame all over the courtyard
he was doing it with half a face i was
actually kind of hoping that they would
test the theory that jon snow cannot be
burnt because he's part targaryen but
they didn't quite take it that far
because then everyone fell because right
after arya killed the night king
but number three arya the hound and
barrick inside the castle this is where
they sort of shift into suspense mode
and arya is just a super creeper
trying to make it in and around the
library stacks trying to escape the
whites until
she backs into the door and finds that
she has to go the exact opposite way
a lot of great kills but the minute that
barrick threw his flaming sword to save
arya from getting dog piled
i knew that he was going down because
like the minute you give up your weapon
you give up your defense there's nothing
you can do to hack them away so that's
pretty much it for him i was only bummed
out that he didn't burst
into flames when he went down you get
that very brief melisandre arya reunion
where she reminds her about that season
3 scene eyes that you'll shut forever
brown eyes green eyes and wink wink blue
eyes which we now know
are the blue eyes of the night king in
the whites the white walkers but mostly
talking about the night king
it's important to note though that
melisandre did not see arya killing the
night king she just saw
arya closing blue eyes and by this late
in the game once they learned about
white walkers and whites
she'd sort of parsed out what that meant
but one of the really cool twist payoffs
of the episode
was daenerys's dracarus where she tries
to give him the biggest drakkars she's
ever given anyone her entire life and
even though the night king hasn't really
betrayed a lot of emotions on his face
the last couple of seasons
he looks up at her smiles and then
reaches for an ice javelin
almost getting in the way that he got
viserion but just to be clear that does
not mean that the night king
was a targaryen he was one of the first
men the targaryen didn't come to
westeros till way way later in its
history
the night king finally raises all the
undead whites up just as jon is trying
to bum rush him doesn't quite get him in
time
daenerys is able to save him but she's
in such a state of shock that she pauses
long enough for the whites to overrun
drogon and i love just watching him
freak out but in this moment he is in
fight-or-flight mode he just completely
flips his [ __ ] flies into the air and is
shaking all over trying to get them off
leaving daenerys by herself
but as you would expect she gets rescued
by sir jorah who gets to ride in and be
her knight in shining armor which is all
he's wanted to do these last couple of
seasons since coming back
number two r.i.p theon in sir jorah as
they both go down i love the way that
they sort of took a lot of the sound
out of the last bit of the episode and
they have that really creepy
somber music as it seems like all hope
is lost
the night king and his white walker
generals are flanking just slowly
walking up to bran
bran gives him that epic speech telling
him he's a good man because theon knows
in his heart that he's about to die
after the night king kills him it almost
seems like he gives him a look of
respect as he walks closer to bran
but while this is all happening you also
have sergiora just taking hit
after hit for daenerys so it was pretty
clear that he was going to go down even
if it wasn't going to happen until later
in the episode
number one of course arya stark for the
win mvp of the episode
kills the night king with the valyrian
dagger with almost the same type of
trick
shot that she got brienne with dropping
the knife from one hand to her lower one
who here is surprised that they killed
the night king halfway through the
season i did a video yesterday about how
cersei is probably the bigger villain of
the season than the night king
for kind of a reason like this i wasn't
totally positive that they would kill
him in this episode but i knew that he
would be dead
before the finale i knew we weren't
going to go into the last couple of
episodes with him still being alive
i'll talk a lot more about cersei when i
post my episode for trailer video
tomorrow so just look out for that
but how about the look the night king
and brand share with each other before
he's getting ready to kill him
it's almost like they know each other
like oh you're the person that i've been
seeing in all my visions this whole time
what do we say to the god of death not
today confirmed dead are
ser jorah barrictandarian ed kono who
was the leader of daenerys's dothraki
blood writers
the little bear and even though ghost i
don't think is dead he's unaccounted for
at the end of the episode
everybody let me know what was your
favorite moment from the episode or if
you have any big questions post them in
the comments i will be doing a q a later
this week but my episode 4
trailer video will post on monday will
you wait for everything click here for
my video about why cersei is the bigger
villain of this season
and click here for my game of thrones
season 8 episode 2 video
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome i'll see you guys tonight
you